smells like pot in here now and it
wasn't make does it anything that's just
that [ __ ] classic rock star it's all
in my watch Sebastian Marx girlfriend
was like unconsciousness her wife wife
he has taken her in front of the Lord I
thought we're gonna have to carry her
out she was literally like we were all
like laughing after the interview she
was unconscious I was tired yeah you
think so yeah it's the only boy she's
not doing it the Adrenaline's not 10:30
pick it up and say six or seven to go
out into a pressed one you're not doing
anything but just sitting there
listening right you saying we just did
the same interview he's done meaning the
same question what's the book about the
Bon Jovi story yeah I mean you can ask
decimal x1 really good [ __ ] awake
though yeah you vaped in here before he
left
wacky tabacky mmm I did I got him to
sign the I got him to sign the dust
jacket
I was thinking about getting it done for
Travis kiss Travis's has been admiring
that poster on the dust jacket this
whole time yeah like a month since we've
had the book but then he asked me what
my name first he asked me what my name
was
that was great yeah good I was like it's
Sam that's right
[ __ ] [ __ ] and by the way you're
both of your names were clearly up on
the TV well how did you know you're not
Sam here's a nose oh I was kind of in
the position like do I look like a guest
no you look fine man I think I'm just
gonna I'm Sam Roberts so Courtney Vance
is coming in right now I don't want a
lot of Johnnie Cochran you know
yeah oh no no no no yeah yeah we're
ready
yes yeah look at that our next guests
coming in the studio right now how you
doing Courtney be Vance is here welcome
to the show man good having you good to
see you
sit down make yourself comfortable take
your jacket off stay a while yes that's
right a lot of them make a lot of men in
here yeah you got ice it's like a YMCA
locker room yeah it's very sad why I'm
saying yeah we're a little fruity I'm
glad you brought a couple women with you
little estrogen never hurts but we try
to we try to keep it as much
testosterone as possible that's right
we're keeping it real
so welcome to the show man people
pestering you with OJ Simpson questions
now just play the character in this
story you you made me like a guy that I
had previously like that much you showed
him in a different light and I guess it
was like it was it was well done I
showed you the light well a different
light yeah the light because he was all
about the people he was you know he took
care of all kind of levels of folk and
he was uh there was a lot of police
brutality back in the day and still is
today and he was he was a really about
take making sure that people had a voice
he mined the limelight either though
they have it made Shapiro look a little
weasel II who was a beer well you know
people one for the people would be a
wonderful world what kind of research
did you do to to get into that did you
watch a bunch of like Johnnie Cochran
interviews did you just go off the
script I did I did and I read I read the
book that the piece was based on the run
of his life Jeff Tuvans book and I sent
up me because his life was so big I said
I'm not going to look at any footage
because it was I was intimidated already
so um I made the choice not to and I
said this the scripts are great and I
think that and I once I saw myself in
the with the wig on and I said I think
people will forgive me any nuance I miss
if I can just assure them into the into
the stories so that was the choice and I
like I like the cute boy Cuba Gooding
did it was that he didn't seem like he
was doing an impression yeah of OJ just
seemed like he was playing this guy who
is in this you know and I find it was
really really well done was out doing
impressions right I think we all made
the the choice that the the scripts are
great we can in this and so we would
just we want to do just enough to let
you all enter the story if we can and
let you enter the store
then you would forgive us and go and
that's what that's exactly what happened
do you like playing lawyers do you like
to argue in life because you've played a
lawyer on Law & Order - I didn't oh yeah
you did for quite a long time yeah yeah
a debate and if I'd like to to argue I
don't like I mean I don't I don't I
don't know if anyone likes confrontation
but I don't
sometimes there's difficult
conversations you have to have in in
life and I don't I'm not I don't like
them but I want to get them over and
done with so some people just don't like
confrontation at all yeah but isn't
there something so satisfying about
knowing you're about to walk into an
argument with somebody and knowing that
your argument is like most unbeatable
there must be there must be a wonderful
when I do what I do fear but then at the
same time you have to because you know
that you can't you can't go and then
gloat yeah so you have to you have to be
you know calm and gentle with you and
the hammering that you're about to lay
down so is there anything that you can't
not debate like sometimes things will
come up and it's like I try not to and
then once in a while somebody comes up
with like oh I have we're gonna go here
no I'm really that you can't that every
time it just gets you yeah they're
topics that I just don't I don't want to
debate about because it opens up a whole
nother can of worms and you know what
are you gonna do sometimes you just kind
of you gotta get in it
yeah we were talking earlier about
Facebook how those debates kind of go
all the way off completely because it's
the opposite of having an argument with
a person because the in person you can
kind of know where the arguments gonna
go but online it could just wild thought
that could that could get very dangerous
because you don't see people's faces
exactly the new on there's something
that you said about confrontation though
saying something to a person's face I
actually see how they react to it in
real time and you kind of know the
effect you have on them whereas online
it's just completely in that that's our
world that we live in that you know my
generation is really the last generation
that that's it that's got a foot in both
camps we were I mean I did there was no
you know email or you know Twitter and
all those kind of things back then when
I was in college so it was I have a
still have all my letters and I said my
mom and dad and girlfriends at the time
you know so it's a you know but you know
I remember standing in line and cotton
the dormitory waiting for the phone yeah
you know the the the one phone in the in
the hallway and everybody had their two
minutes and you had to be very you know
you did I love you too mom you know so I
mean it's it's a it's a brave new world
now because all we talking on the show
to about party lines you remember party
lines we need to share a phone number
with people downstairs and a lot of
times the phone would ring and you take
it up and wish for the people downstairs
that's a whole that's a that's a whole
different world people can't people know
that they don't know 8tracks I don't
know you know they barely know pagers
anymore that was why it never would have
happened without pagers imagine if the
[ __ ] was all cellphones why wouldn't
happen yeah and we were looking at clips
of his old apartment hid stacks of CDs
even not that long LP acts yeah LP there
is there is something less romantic
probably because like like you said you
find a box right of the old letters that
you wrote when you were in college and
you'll read them you're like wow I was a
different person right
whereas now like if I just put my
ex-girlfriends name into my gmail search
well I got all the emails but it's like
I don't we used to remember everybody's
phone number now if you ask somebody
with their phone numbers you know you
know if you lose your phone and you had
to call people we wouldn't know what
people's phone numbers are no way the
mind is a terrible thing to wait for
other things like the memories not
getting wasted on phone numbers and
whole this going being used father's
okay I believe you okay it's like the
fun facts that we post on Facebook
that's what the memories being used for
now but then all the great political
opinions everybody has but you don't
need it because usually most devices
like it's weird to see like in school
they don't they don't have to do any
type of calculations anymore it's just
you just push a button and you get it
yeah
do it yeah when I was young you couldn't
use a calculator now you can use a lot
of that stuff but you still have to know
the you have to show how you get you
arrived at your end write formulas and
show your work to show that you can't
just go boom and no I mean eventually
it'll it'll be you know that you can win
the upper grades I think you can you can
get away with that but in the lower
grades my kids are in fifth grade now
they they gotta show their work so
gotcha so you're having kids in fifth
grade like is it difficult to talk to
them about what a phenomenon like why
people care so much about what you did
on the oj show and why people care so
much about that trial because I would
imagine that now they're old enough that
their classmates are like aware of you
because that show was so big well I
think they're aware of us but we we
don't focus on on who we are we focus on
the the who who they're who they are who
you know who what great what they where
they come from and what what how why
we're standing here on the shoulders of
Arthur Ashe because my son is playing
tennis now and and you know President
Obama and Oprah Winfrey and Harriet
Tubman and and and you know you you you
have to know you know the the country
where but we have a wonderful wonderful
great country but there's there's parts
of our history that we're not proud of
we're not part of part of what happens
to the happen to the Native Americans
and we're not proud of what happened to
the japanese-americans in the internment
camps but it's a part of who we are and
there's we always say that there's one
education you're gonna get at school
there's another education gonna get at
home you got to know where you came from
and so that when you go out into the
world you can have compassion and you
can be kind to people even though
they're they they give you back one
thing you you don't have to return it in
kind you you know you know sometimes
some things you gotta let it go you go
you and some happens at school didn't AG
launch away go your way come home tell
me about it and if we need to get in and
get a go up to school and take care of
it and you know we'll go up to school
and just have a discussion with the
principal about work my son and daughter
trying to do the right thing and this is
not right can we talk about it and and
that's just so that the children aren't
out there fighting when something and
learning that if something doesn't go
your way you gotta you know
you know you gotta go fist you you know
this you know these days you can't do
that have they watched footage of the
real trial and now they understand kind
of what it was no they they we talked
about you know with the because the the
show the OJ show was not isn't that for
them yeah right there the the the
content is not for them but you know the
the we talk a lot about you know who who
they are and what the the time period
was and who AJ was and and so they're
starting to build their their their
cases in their minds about who people
are and you know that I think this this
election was was very important for them
to actually see you know seeing that the
bitterness with which people the the
candidates were going at each other and
how not not being able to take the high
road you know and what that what that
meant you know you know we we always
talk about you know taking the high road
and not you can we can have a discussion
we don't have to hate each other and and
then sing the the the trial the trial
the election and how the the candidates
couldn't do that they couldn't have a
agree to disagree and move on so it's
it's it's a very interesting interesting
time in our country for people that now
to be have to go back and talk to their
children about what daddy you said that
what but why would they so mean to each
other so we've got to actually talk
about why so many parents don't explain
stuff to the kid they uh well I don't
want if to tell my kids that that's the
yeah that's the hard part of parenting
is explaining that stuff right
yeah even like teaching the compassion
even now you know arguments on TV are
being rewarded for being civil which is
just crazy
I bet a Trevor no are uh you know when
he had that guest they're like oh it was
a civil argument that's right I like a
good knock-down drag-out I enjoy washing
but it is it is it's saying that you
have to teach your kids to be more civil
than the candidates running for
president you know what I mean like when
you're like no no don't hold yourself to
the standard there we all the presidents
to different people real psychic
so let's just not try to do do you do
you have to watch out when your kids
bring friends home and probably
especially when they were younger than
now like you have to watch out that it's
not just kids who were put up to it by
their parents who want to see what what
it's like in the house with you and
Angela Bassett never happened it doesn't
no never happens wait they don't kids
don't care they don't their parents
might right if the kids are famous you
know we go to public schools they don't
care and even the parents don't care you
know everybody's everybody's you know
working hard everybody is glad to be in
this wonderful school district that has
wonderful and everybody's paying the
high property taxes to be in the
district so they don't care I would care
I try to get my kid to be friends with
York absolutely for sure I try to see
what was going on in your house
trampoline involved know what they're
doing see if they're doing this is your
first comedy this on OOP scuse me on
camera yes yes I've done a play at the
Guthrie his girl Friday with my wife and
was a 200-page play that we we did but
this is the first time on camera that I
really really let loose and it's a it's
a great great opportunity it's a great
story that you know we need to laugh
right about now we were talking about
how contentious and you know that I
remember the the election you know and I
was like is this real is it it's a dream
right I'm gonna get up and it's gonna be
a different world when I wake up right
and it wasn't and and I think we we need
to as we close we come to the close of
this year we got to figure out a way how
to have some fun and know that this is
you know this is just we're gonna get
through this we all gonna work together
and find our way through it like we find
I went through everything we this
country is a is made is that the fabric
stretches but it doesn't tear so that's
that's what it that's what the film for
well how'd you been offered comedies and
turned them down because you
like I mean you just hadn't been offered
them before and this was this is a
wonderful you know opportunity they
really wanted because it's it's a comedy
but comedy for me is situational yeah
you know it's really about this guy who
was straight ahead and you know this
this company really you know on hard
times and they really need him to be
delivered so that they need his his
company to say sell as save their
company and they're coming to me to
please you know you know let us partner
up with you please we need you and I'm
like I don't really you know I'm going
to Dell I don't need you guys and
they're there please just come to our
office Christmas parties you can see our
culture and we were good could we take
care of people we're about our people
like you know what I've seen the
cubicles in the in the carpet I don't
really need no no I'm not come please
come to our party and they asked me do
you party and I said I used to and so I
go to the party and it's not looking
good and then all of a sudden I run into
this this snow machine right and it's
all on there's a lot of extras in the
movie obvious all the background hardest
background players background artists
artists today protocol background
artists there's a ton of them know we
have fifty background artists because
the scene is so big does it frustrate
you when the background artists start
trying to take attention away cuz Dan
Soder was Dan Soder was telling us the
story about watching the guys I want to
say it's fine i watch the background
artist get fired over having a cell
phone on and then talking too loudly in
a quiet sea oh wow well I mean it does
their acting and this 350 you know
people yeah personalities anybody fired
under set like that I have not
personally but I'm sure it happened it
is awkward
but you you must have the one of the
artists must have done something
he was a they all know what the rules
are
yeah of course they they're they're
artists and they know that they're
supposed to be in the background
they don't make artistic choices when
they get to the foreground this problem
that art is meant to be so it it and
they're you know this is a this is a
very you know there's there's quite a
few foreground artists in our piece and
they're very prominent for going on and
so they you know they were they wanted
to make sure that that there was a nice
little gap in between and that everyone
stayed in their lane and because there's
there was a that we had a limited amount
of time and a lot of work to do so they
were the the soul and heart of our piece
with were the background art they really
you know it's 12 14 hours a day they
were doing you know dancing you know
they would put the musical and to get
everybody get in the right rhythm and
beat and then they would turn the music
off because they wanted to have the
dialogue clear and so they said these
these you know 350 artists just you know
bouncing and bopping - you know -
nothing and you know for 12 hours and
then afterwards when you after you know
being silent for you know two three
minutes scene they you know 20 times 20
takes um the the director would tell
everybody do you you can't talk yeah
that's crazy
because it's too many people and that
it's just too many people in writing
room and I can't I can't hear myself
think so no talking in between setups
and so was I mean it's they they were
and you know this is not you know places
for them to sit so they're just kind of
you know for 12 I mean it's it's it's
it's grueling it's really grueling what
they've done so and what they did and
they really added so much to our pieces
you know as you'll see so hats off to
our background that's a shitty job
that's a really that's a really rough
rough I mean he's a lot worse there's a
lot of ways it's a lot worse yeah
there's worse gigs but that is a tough
thing just nine twelve hours and then
not talking three months yeah yeah
that's
not real months can't look at the camera
look at the camera BIA can't no but you
don't want to look at the camera oh I do
that's why you're not a background
artist I look right into it now Denzel
Washington is doing movie fences yes
which you were pretty well known for
your run when you're doing that when
you're doing the play yes and you know
you got a ton of credit for it as well
it's really fun to watch them
I wouldn't saw they they're the revival
of our play Denzel and foul and they you
know we we had a really we did the play
over a three-year period and re rehearse
the play at every city we were we were
in it at Yale at Chicago in San
Francisco and in New York and so we
really by the time we came into New York
we were a really solid tight family so
you know I can't you know when someone
else does the play and I go see it I'm
you know I'd take that into
consideration and it's tough to be able
to in four weeks to try to get to where
we all got to in three years so I you
know if if someone if a group when
they're doing the play gets you know a
series of moments or half of the play
then they've accomplished something
great because it's a really really tough
play to pull together how do you not get
bored doing the same thing every night
because you you really have to you have
to you know you you realize that the
people that are there they they paid a
lot of money and they want to see a
great show so you have to go through the
the experience every night and buy and
that's how I figured out how to cuz the
the character I played corey has to
mourn his father in song every night and
you know and and their mother when I was
first doing the play I couldn't figure
out how to not how did not how to get
there I was I was always I would dry up
off and dump in mud director Lloyd
Richards came to me and said can you
drive what's going on
I don't know I haven't figured out how
to get there and then I you know and
when I was on Broadway I started to
realize that it was it's about the play
you got to go through let yourself go
through the play and because it's a
great play you the by virtue of going
through the play every night you'll the
play will take you there I had to allow
myself to let the play take me to where
my tryout put him in I had to crime oh
and physically the more and my father in
the song that he taught me and that this
little girl his daughter by another
woman his daughter was had been taught
the same song and from us doing the this
the song and all the moves that our
father taught us both we you know came
to well I came to more and my father and
and so I often times I couldn't get
there but once I figured that key out it
became a beautiful beautiful moment and
today if I ever if I sing the song I
would go because it's just it's in me
right on TV they a lot of times don't
have tears when they cry I've noticed
that too like a lot of times you'll see
them crying and the face is right but
you're not it's hard to do it when you
know there's an television that they
move real fast what's the name in a song
all old dog blue I don't know dog's name
was blue crying Courtney's crying oh my
lover is crying so denzel's writing I
mean directing and starring in this one
it's a film right in the film adaptation
yeah did you reach out to Denzel go dude
if you're gonna do a movie I could have
done it like No yes yes he's a dear
friend and we just I'm so grateful and
and and happy for him it's it's a
wonderful moment are you gonna be in the
movie at all there's no room for you and
[Music]
already it's already done
so the movie is basically just the play
shot film it's a film version of this of
the play right yeah that they've that
they've done for and and I think they're
going to do the whole series because the
August wrote ten plays over the H for
each decade of the 20th century so HBO I
believe is doing is gonna do all the the
different plays but this the first one
which is fences is a film it's great
well listen we have to close we do have
to close but don't worry about fences
because in theaters this Friday yes is
office Christmas party TJ Miller is in
here yesterday oh yeah took over the
whole studio didn't sweater blazer oh
you said that blazer on for like six
years
but everybody go check out the movie
it's in theaters on Friday you can
follow Courtney Vance on Twitter at
Courtney B Vance thanks for hanging out
man you guys dan do you have any dates
or helium Pam comedy club I'm gonna be
there in Philly December 29th through
New Year's Eve